when my parents are making me breakfast  they like make a lot of coffee a lot  because they're peering yeah I once I  have it from my dad junk it look more  like this coffee stop you from growing  that's why I don't want to drink it  because then I would be like this little  for my whole entire life well time is  good I don't like this well from the  scat stick it smells like [ __ ] it's  almost as bad as experice tape like oil  oh my god that's solution I think this  one opens up things again me saying  forever I am I'm doing one to a hundred  it would be zero this is better than hot  chocolate I thought oh it actually  tastes a little better than this